Society has rules and the first rule is
you go to college mhm you want to have a
happy and successful life you go to
college if you want to be somebody you
go to college if you want to fit in you
go to
college well that's what we all used to
think but now our Elite universities are
sabotaging themselves they align
themselves with socalled social justice
activists and race Hustlers over
maintaining standards of excellence you
know what they used to be known for
earlier today Harvard's governing board
announced that Claudine depends on the
context gay would indeed remain as
president and that she's the Right
leader to address these serious societal
issues but the left just doesn't
understand the game that's being played
here they're playing to main maintain
control of Harvard the right knows it
can never control Harvard so it's
playing for control of the United States
and from the rights perspective the most
important thing is simply discrediting
Harvard and the longer president gay
remains in place the more Harvard and
the other ivys are going to be
discredited so the right would have won
if she left but the right will win more
now that she's actually staying the
people who were the most concerned with
trying to replace president gay are
establishment types who actually want to
preserve Harvard's
credibility Harvard should listen to
those people people by not listening to
them Harvard is giving a weapon to Trump
and the populace that's going to last I
think for a long time now many times in
the future The Establishment is going to
want Americans to listen to a professor
from Harvard every time the decision to
keep president gay will make it easier
for the populist to discredit that
Harvard
Professor but again just like we talked
about in the angle this is the world the
left has chosen they would rather
maintain an iron grip on institutions
like Harvard even if doing so destroys
their
credibility but the real question is how
much longer will the left's Allies in
the establishment tolerate this type of
thinking the business Community having
shoveled really billions to Harvard over
the years has a big big decision to make
joining me now is Rob monz an
independent documentary filmmaker who's
been covering farle activism at American
universities now Rob I watched one of
your docu documentaries over the weekend
and I was riveted by it you know nice
job on that but it it was about
Professor Roland frier at Harvard and in
your research you came to one conclusion
that Claud and gay embodies everything
wrong with higher ed explain
that Roland FL Fryer's life uh you
wouldn't believe it because it sounds
like a movie script right he's this guy
who's born into poverty um in a poor
section of Florida he's instantly
abandoned by his mother his dad goes to
jail for series of crimes when Roland's
in high school and somehow Roland Fri is
able to pull himself from there to
become the youngest Professor to ever
secure tenure at Harvard University okay
he's he's in the economics department
and he uses his considerable genius
level IQ and millions of dollars of
money that he's able to raise to
basically investigate the most hot
button topics of race in America he does
not have a particular political agenda
all right there's no partisan agenda
he's not for any particular political
team but his research kept blowing up
some of the core tenants of wokeness
that happened to saturate a place like
Harvard University and his career um a
couple years ago was suddenly cut short
by a very opaque sexual harassment case
that Harvard and its enablers at the New
York Times assured us was completely
Justified because Roland was a sexual
predator on some of his staff and we put
out a documentary um that people can see
Harvard canel roland.com
which demonstrates that that was a
cynical cover story and in fact Roland
got punished because he refused to tow
the line that you're expected to tow if
you're uh you know if if you're part of
the black L at Harvard University and
one of the two people that we
specifically identify as one of the
alpha architects of Roland's downfall is
Claud and
gay and why was she threatened by him
particularly I I I've watched him
watched videos um his comments about
public schools and how we have to stop
you know treating kids as victims and
and raise the bar not lower it I mean it
was just beautiful stuff he seemed
incredibly smart from an econom iic
perspective and an educational
perspective why was that a threat to her
yeah what you're talking about is his
groundbreaking Research into the Harlem
Children Zone right what Roland is
trying to find is he's trying to find
the vaccine for education is he's like
Harlem children's zone is somehow able
to take poor black kids from far-flung
parts of New York City and get them to
not only catch up to but exceed their
white counterparts and he takes about a
year or two and investigates what are
the essential elements of har Harvard
the Harlem Children Zone and he finds
these five core things now notice that's
in direct contrast to what is
fashionable in terms of Education reform
which is if black students aren't
meeting the standards the standards must
necessarily be racist or oppressive and
they need to be sheld someone like
Claudine gay almost all of her moral
Authority is based upon the pro the
problems of a black community never
being solved right and she's also a bit
of an intellectual Med medocity yeah so
intellectual mediocrity of which he did
not have uh she does have she possesses
um so he was really an existential
threat to use an overused uh phrase to
the entire social justice narrative uh
of Harvard Rob your documentary was
terrific I know there are others I'm
going to link it up on my Instagram page
thank you for sharing your insights
about this we're not letting this go hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else